[Music]
Laura
my name is Dr Cotter
I'm a therapist do you want to sit down
okay
I know you're nervous
that's okay
I just want to have a chat
I promise this is a safe place
not for me
why do you say that
come on
let's sit
please
foreign
okay I'm gonna have to ask you a couple
of questions that might sound stupid
what
day of the week is it
Thursday
and the month October I'm not crazy
nobody's saying that no but I need you
to understand I'm a PhD candidate I'm
not some lunatic okay
take a breath and you could just tell me
what's going on
I'm seeing something
no one else can see except for me
I know how insane that sounds I do but
it's
this thing I can't explain it
what is it you're seeing
it looks like people
but it's not a person
I'm not sure I understand it looks like
people it looks like different people
sometimes it pretends to be someone that
I know sometimes it's a random stranger
sometimes
sometimes it looks like my grandfather
who died in front of me when I was seven
but it's all the same thing
it's
it's like
it's like it wears people's faces like
like masks
do you see it right now here
what happens when you do see it
it's smiling at me
but not a friendly smile it's the worst
smile I've ever seen in my life and
whenever I see it I just get this
god-awful feeling like something really
terrible is gonna happen
I've never felt scared like I do when I
see it
Laura have you or anyone else in your
family ever experienced hallucination
it's not an hallucination
called
around me
it's taking over my whole life and my
mind and
tells me things
it told me that today today's the day
today's the day that I'm
I'm gonna okay that's okay that's okay
I know that what you're experiencing
feels incredibly real
sometimes when we get emotionally
overwhelmed or experience an intense
trauma our minds you're not listening to
me
and no one will listen to me okay Laura
it's okay
Laura
can you look at me please
look at me
[Music]
there's nobody else here
I have a patient emergency and eval too
I need staff here no hurry
[Music]
Laura
[Music]
my name is Dr Rose Carter What do you
want from me why is it that everybody
else who's seen it is dead in your life
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but not a friendly smile
the worst smile I've ever seen
not never keep running
foreign
[Music]